you've kind of as a side on your lab
page mentioned that you're sometimes
interested in Astro engineering
uh so what what kind of uh space
architectures do you think we can build
to house humans or interesting things
outside of Earth
yeah I mean there's there's a lot of fun
ideas here um one of the classic ideas
is only or cylinder or Stanford Taurus
these are like two rotating structures
that were devised in space they're
basically using the centrifugal force as
artificial gravity
um and so these are structures which
tend to be many kilometers across that
you're building in space but could
potentially habitat
um millions of people in in orbit of the
earth
um of course you could imagine pulling
them if you you know the expanse does a
pretty good job I think of exploring the
idea of human exploration of the solar
system and having uh many objects many
of the small near-earth objects and
asteroids inhabited by mining colonies
um one of the ideas we've played around
with our group is this technology called
a quasite a quasite is
um an extension again we always tend to
extend previous ideas ideas build upon
ideas but an extensional idea called a
star type A statite was an idea proposed
I think by run forward in the 1970s
1970s seemed to have all sorts of wacky
ideas I don't know what's going on then
I think it's time for Taurus the O'Neill
cylinder status
um the the gravitational lens people
were really having fun with dreaming
about space in the 70s the starter is is
basically a solar Sail but it's such an
efficient solar sail that the outward
force of radiation pressure equals the
inward force of gravity from the Sun and
so it doesn't need to orbit
normally you avoid the sun is pulling us
right now through a force of gravity but
we are not we are not getting closer
towards the sun even though we are
Falling Towards the sun because we're in
orbit which means our translational
speed is just enough to keep us at the
same altitude essentially from the Sun
and so you're in orbit and that's how
you maintain distance a star type
doesn't need to do that it could be
basically you know completely static in
inertial space but it's just balancing
the two forces of radiation pressure and
inward gravitational pressure a quasi is
the in between of those two states so
it's it has some significant outward
pressure but not enough to resist fully
falling into the star and so it
compensates for that by having some
translational motion so it's in between
an orbit and a statite and so what that
allows you to do is maintain artificial
orbits so normally you if you want to
calculate your orbital speed of
something at say half an au you would
use Kepler's Third Law and go through
that and you say okay you know if it's
at half an au I can calculate the period
by P squares proportional to a cubed and
go through that but for a a quasi you
can basically have any speed you want
it's just a matter of how much uh how
much of the gravitational force are you
balancing out you effectively enter an
orbit where you're making the mass of
the star be less massive than it really
is so it's as if you were orbiting a 0.1
solar mass star or 0.2 solar mass star
or whatever you want and so that means
that Mercury orbits with a pretty fast
gravitation a pretty fast orbital speed
around the sun because it's closer to
the Sun than we are but we could put
something in Mercury's orbit that would
have a slower speed and so it would
co-track with the Earth and so we would
always be aligned with them at all times
and so this could be useful if you
wanted to have a
um either a chain of colonies or
something that were able to easily
communicate and Tran and uh and move
between one another between these
different bases you'd probably use
something like this to maintain that uh
easy transferability or you could even
use it as a a space weather monitoring
system which was actually proposed in
the paper
we know that uh major events like the
Carrington event that happen you know
can knock out all of electromatic
systems quite easily a major solar flare
could do that a geometric storm but if
we had the ability to detect those uh
higher elevated activity Cycles in
advance
um the problem is they travel obviously
pretty fast and so it's hard to get
ahead of them but you could have a
station which is basically sampling
solar flares very close to the surface
of the Earth and as soon as it detects
anything suspicious
magnetically it could then send that
information straight back at the speed
of light to your Earth and give you
maybe a half an hour warning or
something that's something you know
something bad was coming you should shut
off all your systems or get in your
Faraday cage now and protect yourself
and so these These crysites are kind of
a cool trick of again kind of hacking
the laws of physics it's like another
one of these exploits that the Universe
seems to allow us to do to potentially
manifest these artificial systems that
would otherwise be be difficult to to
produce so leveraging natural phenomena
yeah
that's always the key is is to work in
my mind is to work with nature that's
how I see Astro engineering rather than
against it you're not trying to force it
to do something you know it that's why
you always think solar energy is so
powerful because in the battle against
nuclear fusion nuclear fusion you're
really fighting a battle where you're
trying to confine plasma into this
extremely tight space or
um it's the sun does this for free it
has gravitation and so
that's the the arson Essence what a
solar panel does it's exp it is a
nuclear fusion reactor fueled Energy
System but it's just using gravitation
for the confinement and having a huge
standoff distance for its energy
collection and so
um there are tricks like that it's very
naive simple trick in that case where we
can rather have to reinvent the wheel we
can use the space infrastructure if you
like the astrophysical infrastructure
that's already there to our benefit yeah
I think in the long Arc of human history
probably natural phenomena is the right
Solution that's as simple that's the
elegant solution because all the power
is already there that's why it Dyson
Sphere in the long
sort of
but you don't know what a desert sphere
would look like but some kind of thing
that leverages the power the energy
that's already in the sun is is better
than creating artificial nuclear uh
fusion reaction